hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute hab ich habe mich gestern richtig
ich habe hier den tisch aufgebaut weil
wir befinden uns gerade in meinem neuen
büro ich weiß dass sie bisschen anders
aus jetzt hier als in den letzten video
der hintergrund wird ein bisschen
angeleuchtet und dann kommt auch noch
ein bild hin und dann sind wir aber
fertig hier deswegen ihr werdet in
zukunft öfter auch unter anderem mal
diese perspektive kennenlernen und
weiterhin sehen und ich habe ja gestern
so viel aufgebaut und habe mir dann so
eine blase geholt vom schraubenzieher
deswegen das tut echt weh egal ich will
nicht rumheulen wir machen heute auf
jeden fall folgendes das paket ist doch
angekommen ich war erst ein bisschen
skeptisch weil ich muss sagen ich wusste
nicht so ganz ob ich der sache vertrauen
kann mir hat ein zuschauer geschrieben
alex check dass malaria gibt es so
pakete von das ist wohl so ein shop in
hamburg der pleite gegangen ist durch
corona und die hat ihn so an und verkauf
auch viel electro sachen unter anderem
halt auch von apple und man konnte da so
insolvenz mäßig einkaufen und ich habe
mir ein paket bestellt für 550 euro mit
zehn produkten also zehn apple produkte
sollen da drin sein wie gesagt ich war
ein bisschen skeptisch erstmal und des
problems auf diese seite gibt es nicht
mehr das ist jetzt auch schon zwei
wochen her ca ich dachte mir aber wir
gehen einfach mal heute ganz nach dem
motto wie es auf meinem shirt steht und
deswegen packen wir das mal aus und ich
bin mal gespannt ob sich das gelohnt hat
oder nicht also für 550 euro muss man ja
auch ganz ehrlich sagen da kann jetzt
nicht das krasseste drin sein weil ein
iphone 12 kostet ja schon 1000 euro oder
so aber ja ich gehe mal davon aus es
sind ältere handys aber vielleicht auch
tablets oder so keine ahnung noch kurz
mit adresse ab ich bin jetzt aber
trotzdem mal gespannt weil ich hatte ja
so viel pech in letzter zeit auch
manchmal deswegen vielleicht habe ich
jetzt einfach mal glück und da sind
wirklich sachen drin
die wert haben ist ja apple kann es ja
eigentlich alles verkaufen
ok haha da seht euch schon mal gar nicht
so schlecht aus
ich lass das mal so okay leute ich und
wir ziehen eins nach dem anderen raus
erst wenn ein stück vanille cola die
beste ko lange ohne scheiß ich hab mir
davon eine ganze palette bestellt hier
vanille gucken nicht bezahlt an dieser
stelle
ok ich würde sagen immer das erste paket
das sieht doch eigentlich schon mal nach
dem handy aus oder ihr kennt sich
versuche ich auch immer direkt den preis
hiermit einzublenden
und dann schauen wir mal ob sich die 550
euro lohnen und ich die überwiegend kann
so zu sagen okay hier haben wir also
sogar mit mit rechnungen dabei die gcl
einfach iphone 8 alter leute iphone 8 64
gigabyte silber allein so ein ding
kostet schon 250 euro oder oder warte
mal ich muss es nach gucken aber vor
allem es ist halt auch das muss man
natürlich sagen die sachen sind
wahrscheinlich wobei hier ist die ist
nichts dran weise neu ist es nicht da
ist keine originale verpackung bei aber
trotzdem
gebt euch das also damit habe ich jetzt
wirklich nicht gerechnet das fängt doch
schon mal gut an
ich lass das erst mal alles so wie es
ist wir machen es trotzdem an vielleicht
jetzt jetzt ist es kaputt ohne dass wir
halt nicht so gut okay es wird nicht an
einen das kann nicht sein wir haben hier
auch ein ladekabel dabei okay das ist
auf jeden fall ein originales apple
ladegerät aber ist mir egal solange das
handy original ist ich würde es mal kurz
aufladen und ich hoffe es geht an weil
wir nicht dann ist es halt ein flop
kommt schon länger hier an bitte während
ich jetz hoffe dass das angeht machen
wir direkt weiter es läuft eigentlich
gut mit einem gut hier ist jetzt gar
nichts dabei außer eine hülle die nicht
das passt ja gar nicht ein iphone 5 5 es
hier muss ich allerdings sagen das ding
ist bestimmt schon ein paar mal runter
gefallen hier ist eine krasse macke und
hier unten auf und ja also das hat jetzt
denke ich nicht mehr so den kassen wert
und macht euch mal an ich hoffe dass ihr
kümmert
das geht mir nicht ums iphone 5 ist das
war sogar mein erstes iphone was ich
selber mag ich war so stolz auf das ding
und man muss ja auch sagen dieses handy
hat ein extrem geil zu sein ich finde
immer noch das geilste iphone also vom
design her was es je gab wobei das
zwölfer ja so ein bisschen daran
angelehnt ist natürlich egal auch dafür
danke ich hoffe es geht so weiter
so jetzt haben wir hier noch 12 34 und
lade körper vorher gut das ist
wahrscheinlich ein ladekabel noch ein
ladekabel ja ok na ja vor allem das sind
leider keine originalen kabel sondern
genauso wie dieses hier aber gut ist
egal machen wir mal weiter hier mit hier
haben wir ein iphone 6
okay ist kein handy von apple iphone 6
16 gb zählt eine iphone verpackung auch
als apple produkt lassen wir durchgehen
da drücke ich auf jeden fall mal ein
auge zu danke dafür
wobei ich auf ebay sogar mal auch so
leute gesehen habe die verkaufen für
zehn euro seine verpackung aber was
willst du damit falls ihr das wissen
schreibt es sehr gerne mal in die
kommentare
machen wir weiter hier mit das sieht
doch auch mal wieder nach es könnte auch
vielleicht nur seine apple watch oder so
aber ich glaube es ist auch ein handy
oder machen wir mal auf ok schon wieder
ein iphone das gleiche h kurz mal noch
richtig verpackt also halbwegs hier
haben wir ein iphone 5 es das zweite und
ich muss sagen das von euch aus gesehen
rechte ist deutlich besser erhalten als
dieses hier haben wir einen kleinen
kratzer dran
das war es allerdings und ich hoffe mal
das geht auch an
jawoll perfekt zwei iphone 5 s ich würde
einfach mal grob im kopf überschlagen
die kosten vielleicht noch so 50 euro
vielleicht 60 kein plan
dann haben wir hier noch einen diesmal
glaube ich originales ladekabel und was
ist denn da noch bei der adapter das
war's und diese nadel zum ausmachen ich
lasse das jetzt aber besser mal so
eingepackt weil im besten fall werde ich
die sachen ja auch wieder lohnen gutes
zeichen es lädt auf jeden fall das ist
schon mal gut ich hoffe du gehst gleich
an warten immer noch
bisschen bis jetzt bin ich ganz
zufrieden also wir müssen uns so langsam
ja ok grob überschlagen brauche ich auf
jeden fall noch eine sache um so ein
bisschen an die 550 euro ranzukommen und
sie dann vielleicht noch zu überbieten
ich sehe hier sind auch zwei sachen drin
eine sache kann ich euch jetzt schon so
zeigen und zwar haben wir hier ja
hotspots der gebrauchte airports leider
mathematisch ich hoffe dass haben hier
einmal airports muss ich auch leider
sagen die sind auf jeden fall gebraucht
kostet sie neu glaube ich so 130 euro
gebraucht sagen wenn wir noch die hälfte
oder so ich werde euch hier auf dem
preis einwenden das ist immer der
günstigste preis den ich im internet
finden damit sie möglichst realistisch
ist und jetzt haben wir hier zu guter
letzt ein weiteres handy denke ich mal
okay machen wir auf kann man das kann
man hier so schön aufreißen es wäre nice
wenn das die originalverpackung
hier steht draufgänger was ist das denn
ja na du schon mal gehört ich nicht wir
haben hier ja was ist denn hier drin
do not accept fcs broken alles klar
machen wir das mal auf zack und das
sieht man mich schön wieder iphone 8
oder iphone 8 und normal doch das ist
auch ein iphone 8 auf jeden fall iphone
sechs sieben oder acht warte mal kurz
ich muss das vorsichtig auf machen hier
ist ja gar keine beschreibung oder
sonstwo bei ok gut wir hatten auch
nirgendwo eine beschreibung oder so was
dabei das ist irgendwie verschollen ich
habe halt leider gerade überhaupt keine
ahnung um was für ein gerät ist sich ihr
handeln dann muss ich das jetzt auch
machen
komm raus in roségold eine witzig fand
diese farbe dieses risiko früher so
stylisch und ich wollte immer holen aber
ich wusste ich werde ausgelacht wenn ich
das mache deswegen habe ich nicht
gemacht eigentlich dumm heutzutage würde
ich es machen ist doch einfach auch mal
wieder dass leute wie geil das sieht so
schön aus
trotzdem weiß ich nicht was es für ein
gerät ist weil man kann das ja mal an
machen um es herauszufinden guck mal
unser iphone 8 ist gerade angegangen und
das hier müssen wir jetzt einmal kurz
tauschen gut lassen wir das mal laden
ich versuche herauszufinden wie teuer
alle sachen zusammen sind vier handys
haben wir
eine packung airports zwei ladekabel
eine verpackung ich dachte eigentlich
ist ein 10 sachen drin wurde mir
zumindest so gesagt aber gut ich gebe
mich an sich zufrieden also es könnte
auf jeden fall über 600 euro sein
leute was geht das hier ist ein ich bin
so dumm ist ein iphone 6 s60 arbeit in
roségold ich hätte auch so an der kamera
erkennen können oder das iphone 8 hat ja
hier dann so eine sonne das so ein
bisschen klassiker sag ich mache ich
muss sagen es war ein flop also ist kein
narr ist es schon dumm eigentlich bevor
ich euch jetzt aber den gesamtpreis
sagen wollt ihr euch einmal auf meine
umfrage hinweisen die ich gerade
gestartet habe und zwar weil es wirklich
um viel mehr geld geht diesmal ich habe
ja gesagt ich will auf jeden fall diese
saturn box für 3400 euro bestellen dann
steht aber auch zur auswahl eine
mediamarkt box für 1000 euro mit der ich
gerne erstmal anfangen würde stimmt da
gern mal ab soll's die mediamarkt box
werden oder die saturn box weil wenn
jetzt sagt mach erst direkt diese saturn
box für 3100 euro wäre das auch okay ihr
könnt das entscheiden macht mit bei der
umfrage würde mir sehr helfen und dann
schauen wir macht das paket hatte einen
gesamtwert von knapp 520 euro also habe
ich eigentlich - gemacht wollte und auch
irgendwie oder weil ich muss sagen ich
denke mir immer bei so insolvenz
geschichten dass man da halt schon
profit machen kann anscheinend aber es
waren kleiner flop ist also ich hab mir
gedacht weil wir lange nichts mehr raus
gehauen haben an euch schreibt einen
kommentar irgendwer von euch bekommt
dann dieses iphone 6 es in roségold
einfach irgendwas kommentieren die
anderen sachen stehen wie immer auf
meinem shop zum weiterverkauf lake
bonn.de sektors käme ab und diesmal habe
ich noch ein gutscheincode für euch alex
w da bekommt ihr zehn prozent auf alle
produkte im ganzen stoff also startet
rein und wir sind uns freitag glaube ich
wieder gibt es neues geiles video und
dann bin ich mal gespannt wird die
saturn box oder die mediabox haut rein
deutsche dank wirst du schon abonniert
sehr gern den kanal daumen nach oben
haut rein